remembering ukraine's fallen from years
of conflict
against russia-backed rebels in the east
america's top diplomat paying his
respects in kiev
at a time of renewed tensions with many
more russian forces massing at the
border
president vladimir putin perhaps testing
the new team at the white house
we look to russia to cease reckless and
aggressive
actions we'll continue to strengthen our
security partnership
and close collaboration with you to make
sure that
ukraine can defend itself against uh
against aggression
we're aware that russia has withdrawn
some forces
from the border of ukraine but we also
see
that significant forces remain these are
the troops he's talking about
some have pulled back but around 80 000
still remain probably just posturing
rather than preparing to invade
and they're not the only ones on display
u.s led forces starting an annual
exercise
this week in eastern europe nato
training also underway
all countries have the right to exercise
their forces
and of course that also applies for nato
allies especially at a time when
we see that the security environment is
much more challenging
much more unpredictable not least
because of
russia's aggressive pattern of actions
despite the hostilities including back
here in ukraine
there is still space for diplomacy a u.s
russia summit on the cards next month
unclear though if it can change the
facts on the ground
debrahing sky news